- This is a true story.
- [Interviewer] What's your name?
- Patricia Ann Atkins.
- [Interviewer] Patricia,
tell me where you grew up.
- [Patricia] Born and raised San Diego.
I was in a school,
but when I was in school I was
getting raped and molested.
- [Interviewer] By who?
- By my adopted uncle.
- [Interviewer] By your adopted?
- A foster. A group like group home.
Group home.
- [Interviewer] Group home?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And your adopted uncle?
- My uncle. My adopted uncle.
They adopted me out
as my mom died.
- [Interviewer] So you
mom died at what age?
- I was eleven, six years old.
- [Interviewer] Six years old.
What did she die of?
- She died in an accident,
using drugs and shit.
My daddy was beating her.
My step daddy was beating her.
And he caused a lot of pain in her.
So when she died, she died instantly.
He died an hour after.
- [Interviewer] He died after?
- After, 'cause you know, drugs and shit.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- I'm an only child.
My mama, she tried real
hard to come see me
before she died.
And my adopted uncle, he was
raping me after she died.
He took advantage of me.
He took my virginity.
So I turned to drugs.
- [Interviewer] And how old
where you when this happened?
- I started when I was
six all the way to 17.
I went to prison because of him.
- [Interviewer] You went to prison?
- I went to jail then I went to prison,
tried as an adult.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- I was tried as an adult.
Tried as an adult.
- [Interviewer] Oh, tried as an adult.
- Because of the case I had.
I hit him with a sledgehammer.
- [Interviewer] You what?
- I hit him with a sledgehammer.
- [Interviewer] You hit
him with a sledgehammer?
- Because he was raping me.
If I knew what I knew now,
I would of did no time.
'Cause rape is rape.
Incest is incest.
I have nightmares still to this day.
I'm 33 now.
I'm all by myself running around,
trying to find myself,
trying to find God.
I'm losing a lot of people
in the process of that.
I'm damned if I lose myself.
If God says different, I won't.
I've got a relationship. Abusive.
It's toxic. It's a toxic relationship.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
I got a relationship.
- [Interviewer] A what?
- A relationship.
I'm in a relationship.
- [Interviewer] You're in a relationship?
- Yeah, with this girl.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- She sells drugs and shit.
She talk down on me.
- [Interviewer] She what?
- She talk down on me.
- [Interviewer] She talks down to you.
- Because I'm off drugs.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're clean?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- So I got off drugs
because I thought it would get her better.
But she talk down on me, think she God.
Make me feel like shit.
That's why I'm the way I'm now.
I've lost other people in time.
(crying)
I'm sorry.
- [Interviewer] It's okay.
- And I live on Town Street in a tent.
People steal my shit.
Come here and try to take advantage of me.
Thank God they can't do it.
So the process is,
I'm still looking for my dog.
Somebody stole my dog, sold my dog.
- [Interviewer] Do what?
- Somebody stole my dog. I had a dog.
- [Interviewer] They sold your dog?
Yeah. They sold him for
two balloons of heroin.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- They sold him for
two balloons of heroin.
- [Interviewer] Two balloons of heroin?
- They sold my dog for
two balloons of heroin.
- He's worth more than that.
I raised him.
That's the only thing that
kept my alive, was my dog.
My son, my dog, God.
Now that I get in a relationship,
she try to think she better than me.
I'm still looking for my dog.
God said that I'm gonna find my dog.
My god, my keeper. I'm his keeper.
I love God, very, very much.
God knows who I am
even though I don't know who I am.
She think she better than me,
but God says different.
We're not perfect. We're God.
I believe in God.
God makes mistakes.
So, I'm God.
God, he's human.
People already go
through changes and shit.
People do a lot of different things.
I go through a lot of different things.
But I'm strong. Mind and heart.
Mentally, physically,
emotionally, and spiritually.
If I leave here,
hopefully I'll start soon.
Get better.
I pray every night.
Four times, three times a day.
I know you can't understand me that much.
It's very, very tension.
Because I am who I am
because of the things I go through.
But I'm not perfect.
God's not perfect.
So on that note.
I do what I do,
Honestly, I do what I do
to keep me from doing
what the other girls do.
Selling themselves for drugs and shit.
I'm not gonna do that.
God looks out there for me.
I went to prison, got out
of prison, did my time.
- [Interviewer] What did
you go to prison for?
- I went to prison for attempted murder.
- [Interviewer] Oh, with your uncle?
Yeah, because he raped me.
- [Interviewer] The sledgehammer.
- I did six years, eight months.
I got time, since it's 10 years, 85%.
I did six years, eight months.
Hit all three prisons.
One time. Never went to prison before.
I have not been back to prison since then.
Jail, none of that.
I went to the police, got probation.
I'm out on parole, paperwork.
I'm not on drugs. I'm not perfect.
I just got better.
So, I got better than I was before.
Thank God.
- [Interviewer] Did you
do this with programs
or just on your own?
- Help with program
and people that I can
thank they're my friends.
And people like you.
So, I'm just me.
This is me right here.
You accept me.
This is who I am. Inside out.
This who I am.
Nobody can accept me, they don't love me.
They don't like me.
So I don't be around 'em.
I am who I am.
I'm God. God is me.
- [Interviewer] When I talked to you maybe
four, five months ago, where you clean?
- [Patricia] Yeah, I was clean.
No, I was doing meth a little bit.
But I stopped doing it
because I lost a close friend,
just recently.
Her husband, he left her right there dead.
He took the money and dope and ran.
He seen her dead.
They were in a tent.
I just seen him, I told
him I was mad at him.
He is shootin' up heroin,
shooting up crystal.
This is who I am
and God is gonna make me better.
I believe in God, just like you do.
You're a strong man.
You take on a lot of stories.
Whether they're fake or not,
that's between God and them.
But you are an honest man.
You're not perfect either,
but you've got a lot of heart
more than these males in here.
You are a man.
These men say they're men, they're not.
They just out finding themselves.
But you are a man.
And God loves you.
God loves you just like he loves me.
We're imperfect.
We're normal.
We're not abnormal.
We human and God is human.
God is love.
God is love. Unconditional love.
And that's what it is.
- [Interviewer] Terrific.
Thank you so much for talking to us.
- Now I'm going on my day,
whatever God's belief my day is.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so much.
All right.
Thank you. I needed a hug, I needed a hug.
- [Interviewer] You're a beautiful girl.
You're an amazing person.
- I believe you.
Thank you for telling me that.
I had no body tell me-
- [Interviewer] You're
energy is so beautiful.
- Nobody tells me that.
- [Interviewer] No, you are.
I mean, that's a problem.
Sometimes there aren't
enough people out here
and it's such a.